اعلن رئيس الوزراء السوري رياض حجاب
انشقاقه عن النظام وتوجه الى الاردن
بمساعده الجيش الحر وحجاب هو ارفع مسؤول
سوري يعلن انشقاقه عن النظام حتى
الان
نتوقف مع هذا الخبر اذا لنناقش في عنوانين
رئيسيين اولا ما تاثير انشقاق حجاب على
النظام السوري بالنظر الى منصبه الرفيع في
الدوله ثم ما مغزى تمكن الجيش الحر من
الاتصال بحجاب ومن ثم تامين مغادرته
للبلاد ترتيبات معقده يقول الجيش الحر انه
اتخذها لتامين خروج رياض حجاب من دمشق
باتجاه الاردن وترتيبات اخرى اتخذها حجاب
نفسه لتامين خروج افراد عائلته من سوريا
وبصرف النظر عن التفاصيل فان الواقع على
الارض يقول ان الرئيس السوري بشار الاسد
فقد ركنا مهما من اركان الدوله برتبه رئيس
وزراء التلفزيون الحكومي السوري قال ان
قرارا صدر باقاله رياض حجاب دون ذكر
لمساله مغادرته للبلاد فيما تقول المعارضه
ان قرار الاقاله صدر بعد علم السلطات
السوريه بانشقاق
حجاب ي انصبي حدث كبير لم يعدم النظام وفق
معارضيه حيله للتغطيه عليه سوى تفجير صغير
ومفبرك كما يقولون في مبنى التلفزيون لكن
ما هو حقيقي ولا فبرك فيه فهو انشقاق رئيس
الوزراء السوري ووصوله الى الاردن امنا
وسالما بروتوكوليا ان لم نقل شكليا يعتبر
رئيس الوزراء الثاني بعد رئيس الجمهوريه
لكنه في سوريا مجرد كبير موظفين لا يملك
من امر البلاد شيئا على ان ذلك لا ينسحب
على اهميه انشقاقه تطلب انشقاق رياض حجاب
ترتيبات لوجستيه بالغه التعقيد منها
ابتداء فتح قناه اتصال امنه مع معارضي
النظام تلقى خلالها تطمينات سياسيه وض ناط
بوصوله امنا الى خارج البلاد كما تطلب
الامر اجراءات لوجستيه بالغه التعقيد امنت
خروجه منها كما تسرب اجهزه اتصالات متقدمه
بشفرات استعصت على النظام اضافه الى
مرافقه عسكريه قامت بالتامين وصوله من
العاصمه دمشق الى درعا ف الاردن على
امتداد مسافه تزيد على 100 كيل متر مسافه
قد تعتبر قصيره لكنها ليست كذلك نظرا
لخصوص المنطقه فجنب البلاد خاصه در يعتبر
حاضنه الثوره على حكم الاسد وفيه وجود
عسكري كبير ودائم وزاد من الاجراءات
الامنيه هناك كون درعه ايضا منطقه عبور
وتدفق لالاف اللاجئين الى الاردن ما جعلها
امنيه بامتياز لكن هذا كله لم يحل دون
وصول رئيس الوزراء الى الاردن وهو ما كان
ليتم براي مراقبين لولا ان قبضه النظام قد
وهنت بحيث لم ترصد ولم تمنع لاحقا
هروبها انشقاقات سبقت واضعف النظام منها
انشقاق سفرائه في العراق وقبرص والامارات
ودبلوماسيين اخرين اما عسكريا فثم الاف
فعلوها منذ الانشقاق المفصلي الاكثر اهميه
في تاريخ الجيش السوري خلال الثوره الذي
قام به المقدم حسين هرموش ضربه معلم بلغه
اهل الشام اسست قبل ازيد من عام لما عرف
بالجيش الحر الذي تبنى لاحقا تنفيذ عمليات
نوعيه ضد نظام الاسد خطوات صغير
بوليه بوصف المعارضه مهدت لاهم الضربتين
تلقاها حكم الاسد وافقد ته التوازن الاولى
التفجير الذي طاول خليه اداره الازمه
الشهر الماضي والثاني وصول حجاب الى
الاردن ناعيا تماسك النظام وقدرته على
البقاء ومناقشه هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا من
بيروت غسان جواد الكاتب والمحلل السياسي
وسوف ينضم الينا من عمان لاحقا الدكتور
محمد عطري المتحدث باسم رئيس الوزراء
السوري المنشق رياض حجاب وسينضم الينا
ايضا بعد قليل من لندن غسان ابراهيم
المعارض السوري المستقل ومدير الشبكه
العربيه العالميه
للدراسات نرحب بك استاذ غسان جواد في
انتظار التحاق ضيفي
ضيفان من لندن ومن عمان اذا استاذ غسان
جواد يعني هكذا في دوله امنيه مثل سوريا
يخرج رجل بحزم بحجم ووزن
وثقل رياض حجاب رئيس الوزراء ومن معه
ويغادرون البلاد من التراب السوري الى
تراب دوله اخرى دون علم النظام السوري كيف
يمكن ان تصف وتقوم هذا
الحدث مساء الخير سيدتي في البدايه
يعني انا لا اميل الى التخفيف من اهميه
هذا الانشقاق ولكن ايضا لا اميل الى تخيم
هذا الانشقاق انا مع اعطائه
اي يعني توصيفه الحقيقي واعطاءه حجمه
الطبيعي في سياق الاحداث رياض حجاب كان
محافظا وهو موظف كبير في الدوله ترقى في
ال الادارات والمؤسسات السوريه الى ان وصل
الى رتبه رئيس وزراء وخروجه اليوم له د له
يعني اثار معنويه ربما ولكن ليس له اثار
سياسيه مباشره لاننا نعرف ان تركيبه
النظام السياسي في سوريا ليس لرئيس
الوزراء فيها الصفه التقريريه بقدر ما هو
صاحب صفه اجرائيه تنفيذيه تتعلق
باداره الوزارات والحكومه هو يعني راس نعم
لكن حتى حتى لو استثنينا استاذ غسان يعني
حتى لو استثنينا هذه الصفه الاجرائيه
التنفيذيه هو كما قلت وكما ذكر الزميل
زياد في التقرير من الناحيه الشكليه ايضا
يعتبر الرجل الثاني في الدوله بعد الرئيس
بشار ال الاسد يعني حدث بهذا الحجم الا
يدل على هشاشه النظام
السوري اي هو وجه من اوجه المشكله ولكن
هذه المشكله ليست ذات ابعاد قد تؤدي بنا
الى استنتاجات تقول بان النظام واهن وضعف
وسقط او في طريقه الى السقوط كل هذه
التوصيفات غير سقي غير صحيحه طبعا ال رئيس
خروج رئيس الوزراء له دلالات معنويه كبيره
ولكنه لن يؤثر على بنيه النظام لانه ليس
لان بنيه النظام ليست قائمه على موظفين
ولا قائمه على كبار موظفين او رجال دوله
من هذا النوع بنيت النظام لها تركيبتها
الخاصه المعروفه التي لا فلا تكون المبنيه
بنيه النظام لا على كبار موظفين ولا
موظفين ولا سفراء ولا قناص ولا ضباط ولا
جنود منشقين يعني كل هؤلاء لا يؤثرون في
بنيه
النظام يعني هؤلاء عموما من ذكرتي لم
يؤثروا بالوقائع يعني كم ضابط انشق كم
دبلوماسي انشق كم وزير كم رئيس وزراء لم
نجد اثار مباشره لهذا الانشقاق على واقع
الازمه السوريه واقع الازمه السوريه لا
يزال كما هو قبل اغتيال او تفجير مكتب
الامن القومي وقبل انشقاق رياض حجاب وسوف
تكشف الايام المقبله بان الامور لم لم
تؤثر على المستوى السياسي بشكل كبير وان
اعتقد بان هذا الرجل انشق لاسباب كثيره
منها عائليه لان جزءا من عائلته يقاتل ضد
النظام في دير الزور وتعرض لضغوطات عاطفيه
وعائليه اضطرته الى ان
يغادر لانه مرتبط بعائلته بعشيرته بما
يجري في هذه المنطقه طيب دعنا ناخذ راي
الاستاذ غسان ابراهيم من لندن يعني استمعت
الى الاستاذ غسان جواد يعني كم ضابط شق
وكم قنصل شق وكم سفير شق كلهم يعني في
النهايه لن او لا يعدون
على لا اقول اصابع اليد الواحده ولكن لا
يؤثرون كما قال هو في بنيه النظام السوري
ولا يؤثرون عليه ما
قولك سيدتي حقيقه ضيفك يحاول ان يقول شيء
وهو يخجل ان يقوله ان ان في سوريا لا يوجد
نظام يوجد عصابه حاكمه مع ميليشيات تقتل
وتجرم لذلك لا يؤثر فيها كما تفضل وقال
انشقاق رئيس وزراء او او سفير او او عده
الويه واكثر من حوالي 100000 جندي انشقوا
و وقتل اكثر من 20 ال مواطن سوري وهجر
اكثر من مليونين بالتاكيد اذا كان هناك
دوله لانهارت الدوله ولكن بالاصل في سوريا
منذ ان جاء حافظ الاسد بحركه التخريبيه في
في البلاد ح قضى على الدوله وجاء بفكره
العصابه اللي تحكم في البلاد فبالتالي هو
يحاول ان يشرحها ولكن بطريقه دبلوماسيه لا
يريد ان يقول ان من يحكم في البلاد هم
عصابه لا تؤ
فيهم ان رئيس الوزراء بالنسبه له رجل كرسي
لا يقدم ولا يؤخر والمسؤولين هناك لا يوجد
لهم اي عباره
عن لا هو يقول انه قيمه الرجل اجرائيا
وتنفيذيه في النظام السوري ليست تلك
القيمه المؤثره فعلا في النظام السوري
الرجل يمكن ان يوصف بانه كبير موظفين ولا
يمكن ان يقال عنه انه رئيس وزراء يمتلك
سلطه القرار الامني والسياسي في
البلاد لانه بالضبط لان ما يحكم في البلاد
عصابه امنيه تقوم بالقتل والاجرام وليست
دوله مؤسسات اي ان رئيس الوزارء له وزنه
حتى اذا حاولنا ان نصدق ادعاءات النظام
انه تم اقالته يا سيدتي في اي مكان في
العالم عندما يقال رئيس وزراء تحلل
الحكومه كامله هو بينما في النظام عنده
قضيه قضيه لا قيمه لها وهو عباره عن مجرد
شخص من هؤلاء الاشخاص وينسى ضيفك ان هذا
الشخص الذي يعتبره نكره تم تعيينه من قبل
بشار الاسد وبعد مراجعه اكثر من ع فروع
امنيه لانتقائك ه الجهه الجهات الامنيه
وهذه العصابه الحاكمه فشلت في انتقاء شخص
يستطيع يستطيعون ان يثقون به ليبقى معهم
يتابع المشوار القتل والاجرام هو انحاز
الى شعبه في عندما شاهد ان هذا النظام
انشق عندما شاهد هذا النظام انهار انفرط
اصبح غير قادر على ان ان يقدم اي شيء
عندما خرج الناطق باسمه لم بال الاسباب
التي قدمت يعني ذكر مثلا استاذ غسان جواد
اسباب انشقاق الرجل او مغادرته بانه هناك
اسباب عاطفيه تتعلق بارتباط عدد من افراد
عائلته ربما بالثوره
والثوار هناك اسباب اخرى ربما تتعلق
باقالته كما ذكرت المصادر الرسميه السوريه
التي قالت عبر التلفزيون الرسمي السوري
بان الرجل اقيل امس ليلا البارحه
ليلا يا سيدتي دائما اعتدنا من ابواق
النظام ومن يخرجون يتحدثوا ويدافعوا عنه
ان يقللوا من قيمه اي انشقاق واي حدث يطرا
على هذا النظام ربما يوم من الايام عندما
يهرب بشار الاسد سوف يخرج ويقول ان هذا
شبيهه وهو ليس هو هذا الشخص وربما ايضا قد
يقللوا من قيمتها من باب السخريه قد يقول
انه ليس شرعيا جاء الى الحكم بغير غير
طريقه غير شرعيه وانه فاسد وانه كذا اي
انه اي شخص يخرج اما فاسد او لا قيمه له
او مجرم او انه حقيقه انه مجرد تكميله
كماله في هذا في هذا النظام ببساطه الجميع
يدرك ان هذا النظام بدا ينفرط بدا يتفكك
بنيته لم يبقى احد يستطيع ان يثق بان هذا
النظام قادر ان يقدم اي شيء سوف ينهار هذا
النظام ويبقى فيه ربما عائله الاسد وشالي
ومخلوف هؤلاء الذين سرقوا المال والجاه
وهنا لابد ان نتوجه لهؤلاء الذين يدافعون
عن هذا النظام الى الجنود النظام الذين
يقتلون شعبنا ويقتلون في سبيل ل ماذا في
سبيل بقاء بشار الاسد في السلطه يا سيدتي
بشار الاسد سوف يخرج مطرودا منبوذا مهزوما
من سوريا وربما قد يخرج كما وصفت واشنطن
بوست جثه في صندوق ليس او في حقيبه ليس
اكثر من ذلك سنواصل حديث في في تاثير
انشقاق رياض حجاب على النظام السوري وايضا
في مغزى تمكن الجيش الحر من الاتصال برياض
حجاب وتامين مغادرته للبلاد ولكن بعد ان
ناخذ فاصلا قصيرا ف فلا تذهبوا
بعيدا مشاهدينا اهلا وسهلا بكم الى حلقتنا
هذه من برنامج موء الخبر وانتقل الى بيروت
والاستاذ غسان جواد استاذ غسان يعني في
الواقع او من واقع معرفتك
ومتابعتك خبرتك ايضا ب النظام السوري الان
بعتق دك كيف يفكر النظام السوري بعد هذه
العمليه نعم سيدتي ولكن اسمحي لي قبل ان
يعني اجيب على سؤالك ان اقول لضيفك انا
كنت قد قررت احترامه في هذه الحلقه وانا
اجيء الى هذه الحلقات لاتحدث سياسه
توصيفات من نوع ابواق وما الى ذلك يعني هي
توصيفات تليق به وبامانه من هذه العصابات
والمرتزقه التي تشتغل عند السعوديه وقطر
والناتو وما
غيرها
مقا
ل
مع
ا مرتزق
يل السالف ن على
رقابكم استاذ غسان ابراهيم طهر اهب الى
طهر لبناني عربي بال
المكه ارجوك استاذ غسان الت تلتزم بالرد
على السؤال الموجه اليك وهو الان كيف يمكن
ان يفكر النظام السوري من واقع خبرتك
بالنظام
السوري سوريا تصرف اليوم على انه يخوض
معركه مع هذه الاذناب وهذه العصابات في
الداخل ومع اي الاشخاص الذين يدعموها
والدول التي تدعمها في الخارج وبالتالي
سقوط خائن من هنا وعميل من هنا هناك لا
يقدم ولا يؤخر في هذه المعركه المعركه
مستمره والكلام للميدان وما ين يحسم في
الميدان هو الذي سينتصر في هذه المعركه
انتهت اللغه الدبلوماسيه وسقطت جميع
المحرمات عندما اغتالوا قيادات سوريه في
مكاتبهم وهم كانوا يزعمون السلميه ويزعمون
ان النظام مجرم ويقتلهم تبين انهم عباره
عن حصان طرواده دخل الى سوريا ليخرب ويخرب
استقرارها استدعوا جميع جميع من في الارض
من مجرمين وقتل وارهابيين وهم الان
يقاتلون شعبهم في حلب ودمشق
وغيرها سوريا تفكر كيف الان بعد هذه
العمليه تفكر بخوض المعركه الى النهايه
الى ان
تخ تنظف سوريا من هذه الحثالات طيب استاذ
غسان ابراهيم يعني غسان جواد وغسان
ابراهيم اختلطت علي الاسماء دون الدخول في
مسائل شخصيه وجدالات
وسجالات الان برايك ما الذي سيحدث بعد هذه
العمليه او كيف ستؤثر على يعني انشقاق
رياض حجاب هل
سيؤثر ايجابا
على الثوره وهل سيلتحق بصفوف الثوره سيشكل
مثلا كيانا سياسيا او سيلتحق بكيانات
سياسيه موجوده على الارض مثل المجلس
الوطني السوري او غيره
نعم يا سيدتي انشقاق السيد رئيس الوزراء
جاء في سياق معركه دمشق عندما بدات معركه
دمشق وقلنا انها سلسله من العمليات
الاستراتيجيه المنظمه وركزنا على هذه
الكلمه اي انها ادت الى القضاء على عصابه
الموت قليه الازمه في مرحله واليوم ادت
الى تحرير رئيس الوزراء وسمحت له القدره
ان يخرج من خلال ازدياد قدره ويد الطوله
للجيش السوري الحر الابطال بينما ارتخت جد
العصابات الامنيه المجرمه واذنابها ولم
يستطيعوا ان يسيطروا على الارض بينما ما
كانوا يقولون انهم انتصروا في دمشق طالما
انهم انتصروا في دمشق كيف استطاع ابطال
الجيش السوري الحر ان يدخلوا الى دمشق
ويخرجو ليس فقط رئيس الوزراء ويحرر بل معه
عده عائلات وعده اشخاص سوف يعلن عنهم عنهم
قريبا هذه رساله لكل من يحاول ان يطبل
ويزمر لهذا النظام انه قادر على ان يفعل
شيء ان الجيش السوري الحر يسرح ويمرح حتى
في دمشق منذ يومين او اقل قاموا باشتباكات
في حي المهاجرين اي قرب ال المجرم
قصر المجرم بشار الاسد ونحن نعلم انه فر
الى الساحل لا انه لا يستطيع ان يجر او ان
يبقى في دمشق لا هو ولا اي واحد من هؤلاء
الذين يدعون انهم رجال ويقاومون ويدعون
المقاومه نحن نتسائل عن هذه المقاومه التي
لم تطلق طلقت رصاص واحده من هذه العصابه
الاسديه على على اسرائيل بينما سحبت
جيوشها من من من الجولان واتجهت نحو دمشق
وحلب والمحافظات جميعا لتقتل اعداء
الحقيقيين هم الشعب السوري ونحن نقول لكل
من هم يساندون هذا النظام من ميليشيات حزب
الله وميليشيات ايران والميليشيات الصدريه
انكم اذا دخلتم سوريا غير مرحب بكم احسن
معامله سوف تعامل بها ان يتم اعتقال كما
تم اعتقال 48 واحد من الحرس الثوري الذين
دخلوا ليدن سوا الاراضي السوريه عليهم ان
يفهموا جميعا من ابواق ومن ومن ميليشيات
ان دمشق سوف تكون مقبره لهم جميعا استاذ
غسان جواد يعني بالفعل كيف يمكن تفسير
يعني هو هذا التساؤل الذي طرحه الاستاذ
غسان ابراهيم يعني الجميع
يتساءل كيف تمكن او استطاع الجيش الحر من
اخلاء رئيس وزراء واخذه من على يعني مسافه
لا تقل عن 100 كيلوغرام عفوا 100 كيلو من
سوريا الى
الاردن الجيش الحر ليس سوى واجهه لاجهزه
مخابرات عالميه واقليميه تعمل في سوريا
وجميعنا يعرف ذلك وهو لم يقم بهذا وهو
نسبه لنفسه كما نسب لنفسه عمليه الجريمه
التي قاموا بها ضد اعضاء مكتب الامن
القومي وبالتالي انا اعتقد ان هذا العمل
قامت به اجهزه مخابرات دوليه واقليميه
كبيره اعتقد انها تركيه واقليميه وعربيه
وربما ايضا امريكيه وليس ما يسمى الجيش
الحر وهذه ال النماذج التي نشاهدها على
التلفزيون ابو فلان وابو فلان هؤلاء لا
يستطيعون ان يفعلوا شيئا هؤلاء ليسوا سوى
واجهات تتعامل مع المخابرات الامريكيه
وغيرها ضد بلدهم وضد شعبهم وضد استقرار
شعبهم اما بخصوص التهديدات انا اطلب منه
ان هو يذهب الى دمشق ضيفك الجالس في لندن
الان ان ياتي الى دمشق وحتى ان ياتي لاحقا
لنرى من الذي سياتي الى دمشق دمشق ستبقى
عاصمه للمقاومه والمقاومين ولحزب الله
المقاوم الذي يشرفك ويشرف سيادك انت وغيرك
من العملاء حتى لا نخرج حتى لا نخرج عن
موضوع هذه الحلقه انتقل مره اخرى الى لندن
وغسان ابراهيم هل تتوقع بعد هذه العمليه
التي حدثت اليوم يعني يمكن ان تتسلسل
بعدها يعني عمليات مشابهه اخرى هل يمكن ان
نشهد انشقاق شخصيات مهمه ستنه نفس نهج
رياض حجاب في
المستقبل لي السؤال هل يمكن ان نشهد الان
في المستقبل بعد انشقاق رياض حجاب انشقاق
شخصيات مهمه ب اهميه رياض حجاب في النظام
السوري نعم يا سيدتي هناك هذه ليست
النهايه كما قلت لك هناك سلسله من
العمليات الاستراتيجيه التي سوف تفاجئ
الجميع سوف تفاجئ الصديق والعدو سوف
تفاجئهم جميعا بان الانشقاقات سوف تكون
سياسيه وعسكريه وامنيه ومن كل الجهات ومن
كل المحافظات سوف تجعل من ي سماهم ابو
فلان وابو فلان من ابطال الجيش السوري
الحر يدعسون على اسياد المقاومه الذين
سماهم اسياد مقاومه هم سوف يعودون الى ما
الى الى الاماكن التي جاؤوا منها سوف
الجيش السوري الحر سوف ينتصر ليس فقط في
سوريا بل سوف يكون انتصاره لكل الشعوب
العربيه التي تحملت هذه هذه الاذناب
وعملاء ايران في هذه المنطقه الثوره
السوريه سوف تنتصر لكل هذه الشعوب التي
عانت من هذه الدكتاتوريات العمي لايران و
وميليشيات حز حزب الله ومليشيات الصدر سوف
تكون ثوره حقيقيه ام الثورات للجميع سوف
تحرر الشعوب سوف تتوافد الانشقاقات تلوى
الانشقاقات حتى ينهار هذا النظام وعصابته
وابواق الذين يهللون وسوف تعود دمشق عاصمه
الاحرار سوف تهزم دمشق كما هزمت كل غزاته
على مدار مئات السنين والاف السنين كانت
دائما دمشق عاصمه الاحرار والشعب السوري
هو هو شعب المقاومه وليس هم عصابه الاسد
الذين دائما كانوا عباره عن عملاء لايران
في يد ايران يستخدمونهم لم يشاهد احدا مره
واحده بشار الاسد عندما ا حامت طائرات
اسرائيل فوق راسه لم نشاهد المقاومه تظهر
منه عندما طلق دخلت اسرائيل وقصفت ما سمي
المفاعل النووي لم يرد التزم بالرد والصمت
بقال انه سوف يرد في الزمان والمكان
المناسب ك هو يرد اليوم في دمشق وفي حلب
وفي حمص ثوره مستمره وسوف تظهر المقاومه
السوريين هم المقاومون وعملاء ايران هم
الجواسيس
وهم غسان ابراهيم المعارض السوري المستقل
ومدير الشبكه العربيه العالميه للدراسات
شكرا جزيلا لك واشكر ايضا ضيفنا من بيروت
الاستاذ غسان جواد الكاتب والمحلل السياسي
كنا نتمنى ان يلتحق بنا من عمان الدكتور
محمد عطري المتحدث باسم رئيس الوزراء
السوري المنشق رياض حجاب ولكن لم يوفي
بوعده نشكره على ايه حال وبهذا تنتهي هذه
الحلقه من برنامج ما وراء الخبر نلتقي
باذن الله في قراءه جديده لما وراء خبر
جديد لكم من اطيب المنى والى
اللقاء y